I can specify the output language, the
units in metric or imperial and more.
Check out the link in
the instruction notes for
a full list of optional parameters.
Let's build this feature into our
site in the form of a search within
time function.
We're going to expand our user control
window to allow the user to specify
the number of minutes they want to
take to get to a certain place,
whether they walk, bike,
drive, or take transit.
We could do it within a certain
distance, but in New York City I know
people usually don't drive, and
I think time matters more to our users.
So we're adding in a bit more html here.
We're going to give the users the option
to choose a maximum duration, so
the maximum time they'd
like to spend commuting and
an option to chose a travel mode.
Then we'll give them a place to input
the address that they're interested in.
And we'll prompt them, for
something like their office address.
And a go button.
And we'll add in some additional CSS.
Then, as usual, we'll just add
an event listener on the go button,
to call our new function which
we'll call searchwithintime.
Now at the high level, what the
searchwithintime function is going to do
is use the DistanceMatrixService
to calculate the distances and
the durations of travel between
each of our markers and
the location that the user entered.
We'll create our DistanceMatrixService
which we'll use and
we'll capture the user entered address
and check to make sure it isn't blank.
If it isn't, we'll create an origins
array from our list of markers.
And use the user enter address
as the destination and
we'll capture the travel mode that
was also entered by the user.
Finally, we'll call
the getdistancematrix function,
passing in our origins, our single
destination, the travel mode and
specifying the unit should be imperial.
When we get back the response we'll
check to make sure the status is okay
and if the status is okay we'll
display all the markers that
fit the criteria that the user entered.
And we'll do this in a separate
function since this is getting huge.
If the status wasn't okay,
we're going to alert the user
with what the status was.
This is an example of a more
specific error message.
Let's move onto the next piece to
display the markers that were within
the time that the user entered.
Okay, so again,
we just used the DistanceMatrixService.
We passed in all of our
markers as the origins and
the users important place
as the destination.
Now that we got back the response,
we have to parse through
it to get the useful data.
We'll recapture all of the origins and
destinations from the response, and
also capture that user entered maximum
travel duration which was in minutes.
We have a nested loop here to create one
element per origin and destination pair.
That element is going to have a distance
and duration from point A to point B.
We want to capture both the distance and
the duration in text form because we're
going to display that to our users.
And we also need the value
of the duration.
Which we're going to compare
to our maximum value
that was entered by the user.
If the duration is within
that maximum value
then we'll display
that marker on the map.
We're also keeping track of
this at least one variable.
This is important because
even if we get an okay
response from the getdistancematrix
function, if we don't find any markers
that are within the acceptable
commute we want to let the user know.
For each marker that does appear,
we'll create a small info window.
We'll display the duration and the
journey distance in that info window.
Finally, we'll put a little event
listener on to that marker so
that if the user clicks on it,
we'll close the little info window and
make room for a big one that
has a street view panorama.
Let's test out this feature.
I'd like to stay within a 30
minute walk of my office.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I can see that two listings
fit that criteria.
And if I select them,
I can see more details.
Before we move on, let's review
the distance matrix functionality.